my new book Harlem Nocturne women
artists and progressive politics during
World War 2 focuses on three
african-american women in the 1940s
during the period during the war and
immediately after the three women are
the novelists and Petry the
choreographer dancer pearl Primus and
the composer pianist Mary Lou Williams
they were all innovative artists but
they were also very politically engaged
during the period Harlem had come
through the depression and the
depression brought with it a kind of
radical politics that had always been
there but that really became more
prominent as people tried to address the
sort of economic devastation that the
community suffered so we have the
remains of that kind of radical politics
in the 1940s but also a new sense of
possibility as the country goes to war a
war for democracy a war against fascism
African Americans begin to press for
their own rights and Harlem is central
to that I think Harlem will always be
central to African American life if only
because of its significance historically
so movement really sort of the very
notion of movement basically gives the
book its own momentum and I think about
movement in a number of ways one because
we often think of the civil rights
movement or the black freedom movement
as kind of culminating or having you
know its biggest time and in the 60s or
maybe from tonight the Montgomery bus
boycott through the 1960s and what I
wanted to do is extend that sense into
the 40s to show that many of the things
that we think of that we associate with
the 50s and 60s boycotts and Freedom
Rides and sit-ins were actually starting
in the 1940s and these women were very
much aware that they were of taking part
in a movement it was a political
movement that gave them a sort of sense
of purpose and a vocabulary and a set of
goals and so that definition of movement
is very important but as a scholar who's
an introduced
the plenary scholar I always try to look
for something that lets me talk about
different forms together because it's
hard to talk about dance with music with
writing and all three of those forms
movement is very important so Harlem
Nocturne was completely shaped by my
being at the Institute for research in
african-american studies with my
colleagues with it's location you know
so close to many of the institutions
that I write about it's location so
close to the Schomburg where I
discovered much of the information
that's in the book but it was really my
conversations with colleagues like the
late dr. Manning Marable that helped
shape the emphasis on politics in Harlem
Nocturne I don't know that while
politics would have always been a part
of it
I don't think that it would have been as
central had I not been engaged in those
intellectual conversations these women
definitely had an impact on feminism
even when they weren't consciously
trying to do so I think Ann Petrie the
novelist was much more aware that she
was also writing about gender issues in
addition to racial and economic issues
she gives us characters who are facing
problems that confront them because
they're black and because they're poor
but also because they're women so she
knows that she's kind of pushing that
envelope Mary Lou Williams is very much
aware that she's a woman in a
male-dominated field but she's not
calling attention to her difference
instead she's calling attention to her
similarity that she can compete with in
terms that are very kind of masculine
terms so I don't think that she's as
conscious about being feminist in a way
she might even reject that but because
she is such a pioneer she certainly is
opening doors for women that would not
have been open without her if there's
one thing I wanted them to take away is
I'd want them to become familiar with
these women I want them to go and read
something by an Petry or go and listen
to something by Mary Lou Williams or
know that you know pearl premise is a
very important choreographer and dancer
who precedes Alvin Ailey I would like
for them to
be familiar with these women and want to
know more about them there are many
other things but if there's just one
thing I just want them to know who these
women were